c'est une histoire qui évoque celle de
David contre Goliath dans la région de
lobinière une productrice maraîchère
biologique se bat depuis 3 ans contre un
géant mondial de la construction de
route l'enjeu une poussière grise qui
émane de la carrière et qui se dépose
sur les champs et sur les serres mais
même si le règlement est clair le fer
appliquer n'est pas une mince affaire
[Musique]
bonjour madame mariako c'est Karine
Vachon les jardins du bois de l'ail
aujourd'hui 13 septembre 8h30 il y a un
Incroyable nuage de poussière à la
carrière je prends un vidéo puis je vous
l'envoie
quand Karine Vachon nous envoie cette
vidéo en septembre dernier ça fait trois
ans qu'elle se bat contre un Cécile une
poussière grise qui envahit ses jardins
une dizaine de fois par année c'est de
la poussière est-ce que c'est dangereux
pas vraiment mais est-ce qu'on le sait
vraiment pas vraiment non plus Karine
Vachon est productrice maraîchère
biologique elle loue deux hectares de
terre
établi à Saint Flavien dans chaudière à
Palace elle sert de nombreux clients de
la région chaque semaine ils viennent
chercher des légumes directement la
ferme pour faire ces réserves il y en
aura pas souvent les produits vendus en
kiosque offrent tout un contraste avec
ce qu'elle récolte lors des épisodes de
poussière
alors ici on voit des cerises de terre
on est vraiment sur ça
[Musique]
c'est aspiré par les ventilateurs de
serre ça se met entre les deux toiles de
serre partout partout ça se met partout
partout
pourtant quand Karine Vachon a ouvert
son commerce en 2018 tout était normal
en 2019 la situation c'est soudainement
dégradée et puis à l'hiver quand la
saison s'éclos les premières neiges sont
arrivées c'est là qu'on a vu la neige de
venir noire
du jour au lendemain
[Musique]
à chaque fois que j'aimais la
possibilité que la poussière venait de
la carrière on mettait en doute en
disant mais qu'est-ce qui prouve que la
poussière vient de la carrière
la carrière c'est une usine de
concassage de résidu d'asphalte et de
béton qui appartient à Sintra une
importante compagnie de construction de
route
[Musique]
à vol d'oiseau elle est à 300 mètres des
jardins de Karine Vachon en plein cœur
d'un territoire agricole
quand s'est installé ici il y avait pas
d'épisode de poussière bien entendu si
on l'avait su on se serait pas installé
ici
Gabriel Rousseau c'est le
conjoint passé sa jeunesse sur cette
terre douce aussi loin qu'il se
souvienne sa famille qui exploitait une
fraisière ici même jusqu'en 2010 a
toujours cohabité en harmonie avec
l'entreprise voisine on sait qu'il y
avait pas de poussière avant parce qu'on
faisait mais mes parents ont fait une
culture de fraises en sechant là entre
autres on faisait la belle qualité de
fraises les gens de la région pourrait
vous en parler s'il avait fallu qu'il
aille la poussière dessus c'est sûr
qu'il y aurait eu des répercussions on
n'a jamais eu ce problème là j'ai
retrouvé une photo d'un paramoteur qui
volent au dessus des jardins pour être
gentil il m'a offert ces photographies
puis il y avait vraiment une très belle
vue Desjardins avec en arrière-plan le
trou de la carrière puis la poussière
qui est menée de le c'est sûr que on
avait trouvé la source
on voit le nuage qui se lève au dessus
de la ferme les forêts cette vidéo a été
filmée après de deux kilomètres de la
carrière
un genre de smog fait très beau mais on
se cohérent dans un nuage aux poussières
Patrick Rousseau est conseillé municipal
du district de Karine Vachon j'avais
pris le vidéo pour montrer à mes
conseillers pour regarder ce qu'on
pourrait faire avec ça oui ils sont sur
notre territoire mais
on n'a pas vraiment de pouvoir là dessus
fait que c'est pour ça qu'on a fait
appel à l'environnement vous regardez
voir s'il est en or ou pas
entre novembre 2020 et juillet 2022 le
ministère de l'Environnement et de la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
a imposé trois avis de nos conformités à
Sintra St Flavien pour avoir émis les
particules à plus de 2 mètres de la
source d'émission
[Musique]
mais un mois plus tard lorsque Karine
Vachon revient d'une réunion tardive
avec l'Union des producteurs agricoles
voici ce qu'elle aperçoit
la carrière à Rome
qu'on entend très bien les concassageurs
malgré la noirceur on voit la poussière
ça fait à peine je sais pas combien de
temps que ça dure là on voit bien sur
les surfaces la poussière c'est de la
poussière grise
moi de la terre
c'est vraiment la poussière de la
carrière on voit bien le un lot de
poussière qui arrive jusqu'à chez nous
et je sens la poussière dans mes yeux
le printemps dernier l'UPR a suggéré à
l'entreprise d'appliquer de là-bas
poussière ça se passait au cours du
audience de la Commission de protection
du territoire agricole alors que Sintra
demandait la permission d'agrandir sa
carrière mais la CPTAQ a refusé
d'obliger la compagnie à utiliser de la
bas poussière parce que les
problématiques identifiées sont déjà
visibles par le Règlement sur les
carrières et sablières
or ce règlement relève du ministère de
l'Environnement on tombe dans les mains
du ministère de l'Environnement
à faire sa job d'aller sévir contre
l'entreprise pour qu'elle mette pas de
poussière pour salir les légumes
le ministère n'a pas voulu nous accorder
d'entrevue par courriel il affirme qu'il
suit ce dossier de près et s'assure
d'utiliser les recours appropriés à sa
disposition afin d'assurer un retour à
la conformité depuis 2021 il a décerné
deux amendes de 10000 dollars assisent
pas très dissuasif pour une compagnie
qui fait partie d'une filiale du groupe
Cola présent dans 50 pays dans le monde
[Musique]
c'est des entreprises qui ont vraiment
beaucoup de moyens et elles peuvent se
permettre de payer des amendes de 10000
dollars par jour d'infraction de manière
répétée parce qu'on pourrait pas
considérer les revenus de l'entreprise
puis de se dire ça va être un
pourcentage de des revenus de
l'entreprise qui vont être qui vont
permettre d'établir le montant de la
sanction plutôt qu'un montant fixe ça
rapporte plus de continuer extraire que
de payer à vendre c'est fini merci
Sintra a refusé nous accorder une
entrevue nous aurions aimé savoir si la
compagnie utilise la méthode recommandée
par un inspecteur du ministère de
l'Environnement en 2021
le fonctionnaire écrivait alors au sujet
de la carrière de Saint Flavien le
problème est complètement réversible en
arrosant le matériel les particules se
redéposeraient sur le sol
je sais pas c'est quoi qui aurait pu
nous
faire penser qu'il y aura eu de la
poussière émanant d'une carrière quand
les lois sur les carrières et semblières
et ses régies c'est normé c'est c'est il
y a mille façons de
d'encadrer leur façon de faire puis ça
reste qu'on est sur une terre agricole
je te sens émue quand tu réponds à cette
question là c'est super ce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui t'ont comme fait
des reproches tu avais juste à pas venir
t'installer à côté d'une carrière bah
oui en fait pourquoi vous avez choisi de
nous en parler parce que j'ai plus
d'autres solutions parce que le
ministère qui devrait s'occuper de
l'environnement me protège pas
parce que la CPTA Q qui devrait protéger
le territoire agricole le protège pas
c'est pas normal que ça soit à la
productrice agricole
qui loue deux hectares sur une terre
de pas faire son projet à cause que
l'industriel que des droits acquis
au début de l'été c'est une tra a invité
Karine Vachon et des représentants de
l'UPR sur le site afin de montrer les
progrès accomplis pour rabattre la
poussière mais depuis ce matin faisait
gris on voyait
pas mais on le sentait dans ma bouche le
il fait plus beau
on voit bien la poussière le monter le
long de la paroi
je sais pas si le procédé est à point ou
pas mais oui encore ça c'est sûr
demande l'aide du fond de défense
professionnelle de l'UPR cette cagnotte
financent certains recours juridiques au
nom des agriculteurs dans le cas de
Karine Vachon une injonction en vertu de
la Loi sur la qualité de l'environnement
pourrait théoriquement être demandé
selon l'UPA chaudière Appalache il
s'agit d'un enjeu de cohabitation entre
les activités agricoles et industrielles
même si l'agricultrice est la seule à se
plaindre de la poussière de la compagnie
c'est une productrice qui primait dans
sa liberté de produire des légumes enfin
que je pense c'est l'intérêt général des
producteurs de prendre sa cause là
puisqu'elle puisse produire librement
jusqu'à mes produire ça aide brumé par
les poussières du voisin quoi il devrait
prendre votre cause
on dirait que c'est leur job c'est la
job d'un syndicat d'aider les
producteurs c'est je suis toute seule
ici c'est normal que ça touche pas plus
qu'une personne c'est quand que le vent
est nord-ouest ça touche un producteur
si jamais le fond de défense
professionnelle ne peut pas prendre
cette cause là qu'est-ce qui va vous
rester comme moyen et l'UPR ben on va
regarder avec elle avec de le syndicat
local où ce qu'on peut aider notre
productrice à aller plus loin on prend
une marche après l'autre
il y a rien qui est fermé à regarder où
est-ce qu'on peut aller donc vous allez
pas l'abandonner c'est sûr que non c'est
sûr que non
[Musique]
le fond de défense professionnelle de
l'UPA devrait décider d'ici quelques
jours s'il finance ou non le recours de
Karine Vachon devant les tribunaux